-Our first guest tonight
is an Emmy and Golden Globe
winning actress.
You know her work in the
critically acclaimed series
"The Marvelous Mrs. Maisel."
She stars in...
...which is playing at the
BAM Harvey Theater in Brooklyn.
Please welcome back to the show
our friend
Rachel Brosnahan, everybody.
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ Band plays mellow tune ]
♪♪
Welcome back to the show!
-Thank you.
It's nice to be back.
-I'm so happy to have you.
It is very --
I don't know if it's as funny
to you as it is to me.
You finished wrapping
"Mrs. Maisel."
Obviously, you've done
this incredible show
for five seasons.
It takes place in New York City
in the 1960s.
And now you've moved
on from that
to do this wonderful play
where you play a woman
in 1960s New York City again.
[ Laughter ]
-Yes.
-So this is kind of
your move now.
-I guess it is.
Maybe next, I'll get to go
to the '70s.
That would be really exciting.
-Oh, my God, yeah.
We would love to see you
in the '70s.
[ Laughter ]
-Thank you so much.
Or the '90s.
That's vintage now.
Take me to the '90s.
-Don't tell me
that the '90s is vintage.
-Isn't that terrifying?
-That breaks my heart, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Me too.
Yeah, no. I mean, what's
interesting about this is
I feel like, you know,
obviously, it's a coincidence.
I feel like I'm searching
for great parts
and great writing
and great scripts,
but, um --
I feel like Iris, who I play in
"The Sign in Sidney Brustein's
Window,"
would be one of the beatniks
in the comedy club
of one of Midge's shows.
-Yes.
-They're pretty different gals.
-Exactly.
It turns out there were a lot
of different kinds of people
in New York City in the '60s.
[ Laughter ]
-It turns out not all women
were the same.
-Not all women were the same.
-Yeah.
Despite men's best efforts
in the '60s.
[ Laughter ]
-That's exactly right.
-Yeah.
They managed to have
a breadth of experiences.
So, this is the same playwright
who wrote "Raisin in the Sun"
-Yeah.
-and this is her final play
and it's lesser known.
Is it cool to sort of bring back
a very famous playwright's
sort of -- you know,
I wouldn't say secondary work,
but certainly lesser known work.
Is it cool to bring it out
to an audience
that hasn't seen it?
-Yeah, it's been really,
really special.
Lorraine Hansberry
was such a gifted writer.
So many people know her work
from "A Raisin in the Sun,"
but this is a really
different play
about a really different group
of people
and it's a piece that is
so much lesser known.
It's been really, really special
to get to bring it to life
with this cast.
Our director, Annie Kauffman,
did the play back in 2016
in Chicago
and it's just been the best.
It's been so awesome to hear
from so many people
who were familiar
with her work from "Raisin"
about how this play
has moved them,
and also people who didn't know
her work at all
and this being
their first introduction
to the force that was
Lorraine Hansberry.
-You mentioned the cast.
Your costar Oscar Isaacs,
one of our favorites here
as well.
Oscar Isaac -- excuse me.
And how is it working with him?
Were you familiar with his work?
-[ Laughs ]
Yes, yes.
[ Laughter ]
No. Oscar's the best.
We've had so much fun.
I had, you know, I was familiar
with quite a bit of his work,
but I did bust myself
the other day.
He was messing around,
doing a doing a British accent
during rehearsals
and I was like,
"Oh, you know, your British
accent's pretty good.
Where did you learn that?"
And he was like,
"I -- I just --
you know, I just did it
in 'Moon Knight.'"
I was like,
"Which I have definitely seen
[ Laughter ]
and enjoyed very much."
Yeah. I keep getting busted --
-"You were so good in that,
I thought it was someone else."
[ Laughter ]
-"I didn't even recognize you.
I thought that was
a British man."
-"That was you!
That was you."
-"It was you?!"
[ Laughter ]
-You also have a very talented
young actor in the show,
Julian De Niro,
who is Robert De Niro's son.
-Yes.
-Does that mean
that Robert De Niro
has come to see the show?
-He has.
He's been an amazing dad.
He's come to see the show twice
and he's so lovely.
Julian is
extraordinarily talented
and has just been fantastic
to work with.
But he did come
to our first preview,
which is an amazing like
A++ dad move.
So mean, as an actor.
-Yeah. His first preview.
[ Laughter ]
-Actor to actor --
-You definitely want people
to come at least on night three.
-That's what I'm saying.
-Yeah.
-But he was very, very lovely.
-When did you --
Were you doing school plays
when you were young?
Is that how you got started?
-Yeah, I did, you know,
I did some
kindergarten tree work
[ Laughter ]
that was --
-Oh, look at you.
that was highly excellent...
-You still hear about it.
-...if I do say so myself.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, I started, I started,
you know,
doing -- diddling around in --
That has a --
[ Laughter ]
Just go back right now.
-That's like a stage term.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, yeah.
Doing some diddling --
-To diddle is to sort of, yeah.
-Thank you so much.
[ Laughter ]
In elementary school,
junior high, and high school.
My high school had this really
cool program called Stunts
where the students
put on their own show
and kind of rewrite the words
to well-known music and songs
and, as you can expect, it's --
-So there's no sort of --
no overseeing adult?
-There's not a lot of adult
oversight, yeah.
-Okay, gotcha.
That's exciting.
-So, it's a [bleep]storm.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-But also kind of
amazing and inspiring.
-Yeah, or course.
-I had maybe my most
traumatizing audition ever
auditioning for Stunts
when I was a freshman
in high school.
You know, I don't know about --
Can you sing?
-No.
-You can't sing, not at all?
-I cannot.
Not at all.
-Not even a little bit?
Not -- I would say, based
on the feedback I received...
[ Laughter ]
-Not at all?
-Yeah. It wasn't like,
"Go get lessons."
It was like, "Don't do that."
[ Laughter ]
-From one singular person?
-No, it was like a group.
I got a lot of --
-It was an intervention?
-I had a weird thing happen,
which is my entire all like --
So, when I was growing up,
my brother and my parents
would say, "Stop singing."
[ Laughter ]
-Oh.
-And then I met my wife
and she would say,
"Stop singing."
-Oh, boy.
-And now my kids are telling me
to stop singing
[ Laughter ]
and I'm like,
"What a coincidence
that not one of you
has an ear for talent."
[ Laughter ]
-That's exactly right.
I want to see you
in the next Broadway musical.
-Oh, my God. That's great.
-It's your turn.
-Come on opening night
because it's going to close.
[ Laughter ]
Pull a De Niro.
Come come early and leave early.
-It's a deal.
-So, what about you?
You're not a singer, either?
-I feel like I'm the kind
of singer
who can fool you to an extent.
-Okay.
-You know, I've taken
some voice lessons.
I can get away with it and then
I better get cut off
or leave the room.
[ Laughter ]
You know, I had done a little
audition for some of my peers
and then got a callback,
which was very exciting.
And they handed me this sheet
music for this
slightly lesser known musical
at the time called "Wicked"
[ Laughter ]
and the song was
"Defying Gravity"
and they were like,
"Here you go,"
and I was like, "Oh, boy!"
And went up and did
an absolutely horrifying
rendition of "Defying Gravity,"
where I missed my entrance
about five different times.
And they kind of
just politely nodded me
off the stage after a while.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
And, in this play,
if anyone comes to see it,
my character, Iris,
gives a speech about auditioning
and how traumatizing it is
and I may or may not be drawing
slightly from that experience.
[ Laughter ]
Not to, you know,
throw shade on Stunts,
but it does seem like,
if an adult was there,
they'd be like,
"You can't make them do
'Defying Gravity.'"
[ Laughter ]
-I'd like to hope
that they would've saved me
from that drama.
-Yeah, well, look, obviously,
that trauma side,
it's all worked out really well.
Congratulations on the show
and thank you so much
for being here. It is always
so lovely to see you.
[ Cheering and applause ]
You guys, that's
Rachel Brosnahan.
"The Sign in Sidney Brisbane's
Window" is playing
at the BAM Harvey Theater
in Brooklyn.
We'll be right back
with Matthew Rhys.